but we begin with lieutenant generals
Todd semaa Knight US Army Corps of
Engineers chief general thank you so
much for being here you all are doing an
incredible job across the country
building these facilities tell me a
little bit about what is going up in New
York and how many buildings besides the
Javits Center you anticipate you might
need there well Martha first of all I
just want to be able to thank you for
having us on tonight and all of us in
the Department of Defense I mean our
thoughts and prayers go out to all of
these people that are affected by this
terrible virus and you know there's an
awful lot of heroes being made in these
last couple of weeks as in New York City
last Thursday night and the streets were
empty but you still saw the cops out you
still saw all the the nurses and the
medical people everybody really really
stepping up to be able to to help be
able to try to mitigate this so to be
able to kind of frame this we knew and
Governor Cuomo called us two weeks ago
he has said hey I need to be able to
have some help in New York City
secretary defense Esper asked me to go
up on behalf of FEMA to be able to
figure out how could we come up with
some type of a plan
to help New York City so we basically
created what I would call a standard
design and we made this very very simple
you said you heard in the clip earlier
we've really got to be able to make this
exceptionally straightforward so we said
we need some facilities that are Co vyd
and some other facilities that are non
kovin and then we looked across the
array of the facilities that were
already existing we can't start and
build a hospital from scratch in three
weeks we said let's go find something
that's already to code already has
electricity already has fire already has
wire so water so we kind of put these in
two different bins something like a
hotel or a college dormitory or perhaps
a large area like a convention center or
a sports arena so when I was with the
governor said what can I do right away
to get you started and I said we need to
have a we need to have a building like
tonight we need have three more
buildings by tomorrow night we need to
have your list of projects governor
where you want us to get started so he
turned us on to the Javits Center first
and that's we're working with the entire
Bowl team and this is this is not the
Corps of Engineers this is FEMA HHS an
unbelievably talented team in the Javits
Center the governor the mayor was been
amazing in us everybody pulling together
to be able to basically take a
FEMA hospital a series of hospitals and
put them inside a convention center
originally what came out of a box and
only about 500 beds we were able to
expand to about 3,000 beds and natura up
and running today yeah I mean it really
is remarkable and I'm so glad that
you're highlighting all of these
different groups that are that are
working together how have you been able
to do it on such a short timeframe and
would it have been obviously it's always
helpful if you have more time do you
wish that you would had been told to
start this 2-3 weeks ago a month ago
well I I think this is where again this
is a city and state responsibility but I
was actually you're getting ready to do
a pet press briefing the Pentagon last
Friday afternoon and president Trump and
doctor asked me called me on my cell
phone dr. Esper did and they said what
else do you need general Semaan it-- to
be able to help step up and make this
happen I think we got to continue to be
able to anticipate where that
requirement was and maybe somebody could
say that we could have done more earlier
on but I look at when we know that need
we were called in and we went forward to
did here's the power of the idea the
power of the idea is not to sit down and
try to design several hundreds of
facilities Friday afternoon when I
briefed in the Pentagon we had a hundred
and fourteen identified today we have
three hundred and forty-one identified
we've got about eight gigantic contracts
going in right now tonight across the
United States about 8,500 rooms in the
next couple days we're gonna write seven
more big contracts about another three
thousand it's the ability to have a
standard design and then pass that back
out to mayors and governors and say this
is something that has already been
sanctioned to HHS and FEMA delegate it
back down you can build it we can build
it but then take the passion of the idea
and put it in the ground and that's what
we're seeing marked has really taken off
is this is beginning to grow in little
cities little towns big convention
centers to be able to find a way of
cutting this Delta understood hey you
know I mean you've been given a mission
and you are working really hard to carry
it out at a really blistering pace what
about Chicago are you do building one of
these at the Chicago Convention Center
war lens will we see one of these at the
Superdome so every governor has a list
of projects it's premature to say
exactly which ones are on their list
some governors have made decisions I
kind of told you there's about 15 of the
big ones that we've actually got
approval from FEMA we've written the
contract governors have made
announcements in their states and we're
in the ground putting ozone there's
other ones where the governor wants to
keep working through that and we want to
appreciate the governor's role in this
Chicago is a great example of another
big dimension we've taken on here in
Javits it's non Kovan so the entire and
as you said in the lead in this is where
we're able just like the comfort to
displace people that are not Co vyd take
them out of hospitals and put them in
another facility that's kind of what
Javed's is in Chicago we're doing
exactly the opposite we're gonna take
the McCormack Convention Center and
we're gonna stand up about 3sat 3,000 Co
vyd beds three different sections some
will have different types of capability
with negative pressure neurontin so far
but we expect to have the first 500 of
those done sometime by the end of the
weekend and we want to go very very
aggressive we've got a very very good
contractor on the ground and again
working with this integrated team to be
able to be ruthless and execution we do
not have time to do the perfect solution
we've got to do mission essential
whatever you would want to do to make
sure your loved one is take care of
that's what we're gonna draw the line
all right sir quickly if you can and I
just have one more question for you in
terms of the military participation with
health care providers because one of the
things that have been said about all
these facilities is that there just
aren't the medical professionals to man
all of these things once they're built
how much of a role is the military gonna
play and will there be enough doctors to
service all of these facilities so
marked I'm a good soldier I stay in my
lane I see this as a three-legged stool
you have to have the sights that's what
we're doing is helping the sights number
two is you have to have the supplies
you've seen a lot of discussion on all
the different supplies are in there and
number three is you have to have the
staff we're primarily focused on the
site but the Department of Defense is
extremely focused on taking whatever
they have and pushing them out
Javits today there are Army Field
hospitals that are doing the job just
like the comforts up there to be able to
augment and dr. Esper is looking at
other places to be able to continue to
augment existing capabilities with what
DoD has yeah I think it's gonna be
you're gonna you're gonna find it at the
end of the day I don't think the sites
are gonna be the critical path I think
you're gonna go back to the staff are
probably going to be the most critical
demand in a couple weeks from now you
know what as I say goodbye to you I want
to put something up on the screen this
is a poster that says you give us the
armor and we'll give it hell and it's
next to one from World War two with a
pilot you give us the fire and we'll
give them hell and you can see as you
say that the frontlines in this fight as
in world war two this time it is these
medical professionals and its doctors
day in America quick thought on that
before I let you go sir we're just awful
proud to be part of this federal team I
mean from the president the vice
president secretary of defense everybody
said wherever we need to step up and
help the cities in the states we're all
in so just proud to be part of a very
very historic team but we had a lot of
work to do and we can't take our eye off
the ball we're going to make this happen
fast well I I know you're working as
hard as you can and you're a very strong
proponent of the work that you all are
carrying out we thank you for being here
I Lieutenant General Semin I thank you
sir